this film has been a huge hit with
audiences worldwide and everything in
the film is bombed yeah I mean it's good
sense of humor of course and the music
was on point the fans have been talking
about this movie online for months and
we've got some questions for it you all
Deadpool has this is for everyone
Deadpool has many great qualities but
what is your favorite can you all just
is that him as a personality or the
movie let's just say hmm quality no it's
about his taste in masturbatory
accoutrement wonderful use of leather
chaps
I relate and love his self-loathing
that's something we often talk about
he's just a guys to see this sort of
shame spiral a highly militarized shame
spiral and it's fun to watch and that's
something I've always connected to the
character and certainly the meta aspect
I mean I feel like a kind of like a pop
culture machine when I'm at home with my
wife just talking about anything so I
love pop culture and Deadpool loves pop
culture and that's that's why I felt a
little bit like for me like a match made
pencil that's great just this next
question is for Ryan and Tim what was
your favorite thing to shoot and why
yeah sex montage was the worst scene it
was it was the literally I yeah I feared
that day like no other because you know
I'm not I'm not very good at sex in my
personal life if I couldn't you know I
couldn't relate to yeah
except pegging the internet I I guess
month I think my favorite scene had to
be the final moment between Deadpool and
Vanessa when he takes off the mask it
was just such a powerful moment it's
like full circle
yeah and Bryan and mareena crushed it I
mean it was just such a powerful and you
know I think people have said that this
first time for me so I don't have
anything to compare to but people say
usually the ending in the movie is the
hardest thing to get right but I felt
like we had that right right immediately
and it made everything else to sort of
fall into place and you provide that
down set I did I cry I cry did you
really I just completely lose my mind
punching everything in sight and every
hit second word is [ __ ]
and I tend call Scott and I just he's
just like this weeping Kleenex let's
feel like you got the shot right
beautiful
we're so freaky together that I knew
they were going to end it was so well
done that's why it was really so and you
just sit there and you go as a director
you go holy [ __ ] it's awesome it's so
good and and I don't have to do anything
yeah just bear witness yeah I had the
greatness of our great team well this
question again is for you know reminds
him in Simon's I mean salt and pepper
music was in the movie shoot yeah and we
we also got to perform at the mtv movies
award what made you choose that song to
be a part of Deadpool good question I
remember is it if Ian's idea
someone that was another producer on the
movies works with me Adithya Sood
it was his idea actually we were looking
for like Brian said a big part of the
the comic and the movie is pop-culture
references and some of them were scarce
some of them were things that we grew up
loving some of them were you know stuff
that's out there right now and we were
looking for a song that all of us loved
and her upload and the day thea had the
idea of using shoot and it just kind of
perfectly fit into the movie and became
kind of like an anthem for the movie and
yeah you can't get rid of us now you
know if we're lucky enough to have the
opportunity for a sequel dad was going
to fight salt pepper in the sea pepper
will lay you out okay let's watch a clip
from the making of a documentary from
blu-ray this first clip introduces the
creative team behind that pool as they
tell the story of getting Deadpool off
the ground roll clip can also say that
video is so sexy [ __ ] hot Thanks but
he's bad at sex so bad we've heard that
a lot
we were a lot of guys first what point
anyone can answer this at what point
during the process did you feel like you
cracked Deadpool for the big screen
oh that's a good question I think I
think our first litmus test is just does
it make us laugh as we're writing it
like I think when as you sit there and
type you know sometimes you you get into
the scene it's almost as if the
characters are acting all ready for you
in a strange way and if that's making
you laugh from from the inception I
think you're probably on to something
we've always I think felt like
entertaining each other is what we
really do and then the hope is that that
then entertains the masses this is taken
for granted that I knew the script was
great so I felt like the film would be
great there were some big unknowns
though and she and Ryan in the costume
for the first time when I felt like I
said holy [ __ ] this is gonna work yeah
Ryan and I but we got we I cried there
I'm sorry and I thought oh my gosh the
costume had balls is that what you think
like it's someone's nut balls built-in I
brought those but the camera makes you
independent kind of like a bit making
the suit was like a slow-motion nervous
breakdown the whole time because you're
just thinking we don't get this right we
are 100% [ __ ] and and and as we as it
was being developed in design you know
we had all these notes we wholly thought
it was just like we had no time I mean a
studio greenlit the movie and basically
ten months from our first day of
shooting we were on the big screen and
that's no time for a film like this so
Wow
so we had to get that suit right and
fast and when it was finally completed
we went into this little warehouse in
Los Angeles and rushed shankle who is
the owns this film illusions company
that makes these suits he had it there
and like a perfect light and like
sitting on a mannequin and we cried I
mean we just wept because it was it was
it right out of the page
not only that we felt like we finally
created a comic book character that was
it was the most most faithful adaptation
from a comic to film suit that I'd ever
seen and I thought that was that was
pretty special
it was awesome yeah Retin Paul did any
of your own roommate experiences
influence the dynamics between Wade and
the line a line down brother and Paul
crashed on our couch for about two
months without paying rent so so yeah I
think some of that was out of plan over
yeah I mean I do build the IKEA and
Rhett does pay the rent okay gals the
consummate roommate I mean Deadpool's
with the hideous yeah some of that does
come from personal stuff too it's like I
I did have IKEA furniture I always had
to build it on my own I'm at least handy
person I'm a writer or anything whatever
can relate these are handy person in the
world and you like you would place a
newspaper in my dining room table and it
would start doing piss like a shoddy
construction yeah okay this next clip
touches on Deadpool iconic costume and
the extensive work that went into making
sure the suit look right roll clip okay
so where's the weirdest place you've
worn the Deadpool suit I mean this where
is the weirdest thing like to be totally
honest that the one thing I thought was
really fantastic is a lot of a lot of
kids have been reaching out you know
because they look up to dead put a lot
of kids who are suffering from cancer
and that's what they can and you know
I've gotten to know a lot of these kids
just based on Deadpool they love this
character Wade Wilson who basically is
given his diagnosis and flips at the
bird and it's something that a lot of
these guys but guys and girls really
relate to and I got to spend a lot of
time with
kids and do a lot of stuff with
make-a-wish Foundation and I always want
to wear the suit when you go into the
awesome but the problem is the suit is
mostly weapons
you know like Captain America has a
shiny shield Thor has like a semi
non-threatening camera
I have katanas in like annex any
automatic pistols which I have something
you'd go through a metal detector a
hospital in so I've always wanted to
wear it there because I think it would
be really special
they will attest they'd be like where's
the yeah hold on though they are
everything know what one day we got to
figure that out so but other than that I
feel like I'm wearing it every other day
I mean we're doing something if I just
let Fox run my calendar I would make
appearances at random Ohio state fairs
no but I do have a suit at home I'd hate
with the suit
there was no we're not gonna leave with
the suits doing this they remind me that
promotions just doesn't end right yeah
you just go last problem but you have a
successful movie so that oh great Edie
is it better playing a hero or a villain
it's good playing is it's wonderful
playing a villain when you have a
director like Tim Miller or your
opposite someone like Ryan Reynolds when
you have words written by people like
these two gentlemen next to me you know
it's wonderful you know in that position
but Ryan will say as one for being a
hero when you're surrounded by it
everything except me probably but but
now I mean it's when it's a well written
and a rounded character then it's it's
great but I don't only want to play
villains my bone structure lends itself
to the darker side of the character and
somehow I seem to be able to summon the
darkness that's why there's a British
person ever played a hero
I want to be the first and you played it
so well wait wait wait I said he didn't
always play it like a veil I mean he had
his own convictions and it's you know
whether they're opposing to the heroes
or not it sort of sort of lends itself
to making him the villain but I love
that you didn't you know it was hard the
mustache you know when you were twenty
were talking anything you know when did
you know that Deadpool that you've got
it right with the movie as a whole it's
like you know I'd send me in Tim well I
don't know Tim answer this differently
but I certainly never thought that we
had it I'd never always thought like I
was surfing and thin line and was you
know I had these concerns the whole way
that I didn't want it to be this
mustache twirling cat stroking villain
so it was you know it only was when I
watched the movie that I was like okay
we did all right you know as a wife that
wasn't cliched but um yeah we never
really felt like we've got it yeah that
creative process scared didn't we
totally got it yeah but when we were
doing it I was like oh man you know I
hope this isn't too you know right there
I can lay down and you can go to work
warehouse why is that right right that
see me that's great oh sorry sorry ed
did some great scenes but that scene
where he's talking to Ryan and
explaining how this process is gonna
work yeah and it's so [ __ ] good it was
Ryan's idea to again we're trying to
take the edge off the whole moustached
world
Ryan's like what if he's just eating
some broccoli dude it's all good
so we're like yeah there's a great idea
but but you notice when Eddie eats
broccoli it's like his face I don't know
what it is but your facial structure
it's like everything's moving underneath
and the way the light I usually move
when people talk
but it's just as beautiful
one of my favorite shots at home it was
it but you can't add the director you
sit back behind the monitors and just
want it when it works it's just
wonderful
yeah but it doesn't work he just he
doesn't call cut he just goes wrong
everybody else cries and I asked it for
comments after like what could I do
better as a director and one of them was
don't yell across the set you suck to me
than anyone else abuse across the senso
and bunch of guys make okay so Ryan
who's the bigger villain Ajax from
Deadpool or dusty Lee from just friends
dusty I gotta say you know I am in the
room right now yes
sorry do you play the guitar like you
have 16 fingers I don't know the steely
did yeah I would I definitely I gotta go
it's I gotta go with Edie because I
don't know that dusty Lee could could
fight as well yeah burning building with
a naked man where you start singing I
swear ok so next up we'll see the
complex process applying skin
prosthetics to Ryan Reynolds in order to
transform him into this tongue twister
ya know it was a bigger Deadpool alright
of course a real on-camera face how does
that make up when they when they
greenlit the movie maybe the second
thing that Ryan said was Tim you got a
call bill Corso yeah guy called bill
Corso he's the best there is
get if he worked lock him in who's he
working with while you did Lemony
Snicket's Foxcatcher and changing Steve
Carell and Channing Tatum
Star Wars copious amounts of prosthetics
and and still maintain the person
underneath that's the magic of that it's
easy to just slap bunch of foam on
something right person but I was really
keeping the personality alive underneath
this is it is it a feat you know and he
would he would put that thing on my face
every day and it looks all lovely in
fast feet but he would get it on in like
the second he was done after like four
hours I'd go get it off so sweaty you
know but after a few hours it gets
warmed up and it moved into the
beautiful things I made my daughter cry
every time she gets that though at the
end of the day Ryan would peel it off
and roll it up in little balls and throw
it at guys I said a raft
it was cigrip but be like you are
okay this next clip showcases
one-of-a-kind motorcycle rig that was
used to shoot some of the highway action
throughout Deadpool roll clip that was a
real a real city street you guys shut
down can you tell us a little about
shooting in Vancouver like yeah that's
my hometown so that's nice for me yeah I
became public enemy number one because
we shot on this viaduct that we shut
down for two weeks so at first it was
like you know movie shutting down the
the viaduct so traffic's gonna be a
little gnarly for the next two weeks
sorry yeah and then like immediately the
following week on the front page was
just Ryan Reynolds ruined City but they
do the announcement for the radio did he
really wreck traffic that badly but it
was nice it was really nice shooting in
my hometown and just in just being there
and you know and these guys are tim is
really good at making you know $1 look
like $10 and you know fox gave us to
shoot the entire movie they gave us 47
dollars in a bag of skins out yes but
you know Vancouver really lends itself
to it to a huge production value when
they have great production services so
it was it was really special for me yeah
the local crew of amazing a wonderful
place to live and work for four months
beautiful yeah you guys mind taking
questions from the audience at all love
to if you guys have any questions let us
know okay she's gonna come with them I
can't see anything beyond a blinding
light
while those pitches that's for sure I
really do genuinely want to see a
Deadpool han solo team oh I have a non
vocal unwritten commitment by Harrison
Ford
I didn't even actually need that
astrological chart it looks good for us
yeah I don't know that's all in motion
right now we're trying to see what you
know what's gonna come of it but it's a
that's a that's a tricky thing to kind
of announce sort of phrase it's all
based on Adam Sandler's really that was
a bad joke it was good it was like
really I don't even need to hit the gym
or I just stroke his ego for an hour and
I'm we have a question I would have to
isolate 47 dollars in cost money I don't
know what aesthetically would you have
wanted 3d tuned I think it was just time
honestly but you know we did the little
test that leaked at one point
Ryan's producing partner Jonathan
Commack Martin called in a favor at one
of the stereo D and we did a 3d test of
that
slow-mo motion as he's about to cut the
guy's head off okay awesome mm-hmm
but I don't know I I personally am NOT
the biggest fan of 3d it just with I
think technology will get better but I
don't like it the way it takes in the
glasses and takes 30% of the brightness
off yeah so the new projectors are
really gonna help that and it's going to
look better like laser IMAX is really
helps that issue and and and other laser
projectors come in the market but yeah I
I wasn't I wasn't upset I don't care for
3d because I got to pick the glasses
over my glasses yeah
it takes away a little bit from the
communal experience of being in a movie
theater I feel separated than anybody
you know anybody else hey Ryan this
question for you
you often described Deadpool as a
horrible relationship breaking up
getting back together and finally
getting married
how does it feel knowing at this point
that Deadpool is the number one rated R
movie of all time
without China yeah this rated R in
America and ready to [ __ ] you in China
yeah look it feels great I mean to be
perfectly frank I since the movie became
that big I've been insufferable I mean
this this group of people I mean for me
it's been an 11-year journey and for
this group it's been six years and
change and you know we've all had our
ups and downs and our moments in between
and it did feel like a shitty
relationship I mean it was like when
we'd be we would be standing at the
altar and then it would be off and it'll
be on they'd be off and it finally
happened and you know thank God for the
Internet and thank God for the fans
because I always say that and it does
sometimes sound like you hear a lot of
actors to thank the fans and they the
fans I've sort of sounds like rhetoric
but it's real I mean they they they
pushed this movie over the hump that we
couldn't do you know we couldn't get it
made and and a studio god bless him were
they didn't understand it they didn't
believe in it fully they didn't kind of
hell what it was and the fans let them
know that they could make this movie
they could make it in the most authentic
way that Deadpool fans with respect and
love and they did Wow Wow no way that's
you were the one guy with the little
Deadpool that the first comic which is
that what he cares the one it is for
series that's already sweet people so I
met some some people the other night we
did the MTV movie worth and well some
people who like you had the first comics
ever and they were they were so thrilled
that we did that the character justice
oh great
thank you so much yeah and yeah that's
why but that's why we shot we've got to
shoot this movie on 47 dollars in a bag
of Skittles
but we got to make it the right way and
and and we had people here that knew how
to do that knew how to give because we
just needed to put that character on the
screen in the right way and and you know
everything else would fall into place so
yeah we're in consider ourselves lucky
you're welcome just yeah question for
Deadpool do I have any advice for
upcoming superheroes your upcoming
that's a tough one I don't know you know
try to have the the Marvel logo at the
beginning of your film for me and then
what was the second half of the question
like a Deadpool team-up Oh God to her
tour oh good luck I don't think that was
his Christian name Deadpool's tough to
team up with a bunch of people because
he's kind of meta and knows he's in a
comic book movie and it's sort of you
know it's a discussion we always have
which is that can you can you put
Deadpool in a room with with magneto
that's hard to do so but but in truth in
the comics the best parts of the comics
of when he meets up with other people
and you know I'm reading x-force at the
moment yeah yeah and it's like you know
whenever you bring any character you
bring in it makes it so interesting and
you know III every night go to sleep
imagining a truce between everyone and
and you know spider-man being able to
meet up with their poor Wolverine and
you know obviously the possible
introduction of cable and I mean it's
there's so many abilities that there
would be a lot of fun you know I pay top
dollar my son always talked about Deb if
they're poor MIT Michael
from the towels they would be the best
right Atwood I can't remarry but I do
think red and Paul take note because you
might have just cracked Deadpool - yeah
like that anyone else
maybe altering or affecting how you guys
are planning for the future I think it's
changed a lot both in terms of the
rating and even just the approach it's I
think the reason the movie one of the
reasons and movie so successful is
because it did break a lot of the
paradigms and the models of the genre
and so there is a challenge to make
these movies feel fresh and original I
don't know that any movie will feel as
fresh and original as this one did but I
know other studios and Fox are much more
open to the idea of r-rated superhero
films than they would have been you know
three months ago and and and for us and
we've all said this in different forms
in different times we were surprised by
how successful the movie was like we
really believed in the film creatively
and we thought we could make a film that
was true to the comic and that fans
would love it and we didn't know that
the rest of the world would embrace it -
and they did and I think it's because
it's unique very Annie can I just say
that you know making a movie that is as
different as this is I think you know
it's it's scary for everybody especially
people right into check and Simon
provided covering fire like yeah like I
haven't I mean I don't know the business
well enough but I you know you hear the
stories and how bad it can be
and Simon's protected us it's almost
kind of a bridge between us in the
studio that he they trust him
you know he said just let let them go do
the movie that their I need to make and
and because of that we worked hard
together yeah yeah because it is not a
also can empathize with the studio yeah
cutting a check this is still a big
check I know this movie is a smaller in
terms of supergirls he's still you know
it's scary yeah it's a big it's a big
investment than the lesson yeah Simon's
constantly being there saying I know I
know what it looks like I know this
looks really like a train wreck it's
gonna be alright
alright gotta have that calming effect
in Europe yeah in your position yes for
me it you had a naked fight scene with
Ryan
we had many off yeah
was there any close calls with
Deadpool's fun sec with Deadpool is that
what you're called no I mean it was I
think yeah I mean there's a lot of
people around the world very jealous of
me maybe if they were there on the day
with all the rusty metal wheelchairs on
fire was also man it was awesome I don't
know I mean there were so many great
days in the workshop but there was one
day in particular when I'd already done
a second unit day with one of the
doubles and then Ryan came in and they
were all a bit sheepish about me and him
working together and you know the first
20 minutes I wasn't in and I was like
come and put me and I've been chained
it's good and when we went in after that
it was one of the best days I've ever
had on set you know and it was it was it
was great and we pretty much did every
take the two of us yeah and it was it
was it was wonderful with that is great
in the fight scenes - he's very good at
that stuff so yeah yeah and even even
seriously like 14 hours in edge like
don't let the stunt guys do this take
let me let me get in there
and Ryan was so exhausted because he had
to do to make up for six hours before
that in that a Lionel spike scene he
fell asleep for a minute while he was
hanging there and the two longest days
I've ever had on set is that day because
that was 12 23 and a half hours shoot
day for me enough for everyone else just
because if bill Corso as well was there
for as long as I was and ironically the
other longest day was a hunt Wolverine
and it was that I did two units at once
and I did a 23 I was somewhere around
tried 23 hours in labor so it's fighting
make it harder easier more terrifying
situation when a man not wearing a
stitch of clothing is penis hanging out
is coming at you to fight I mean that
happens to me there is a Ryan sized hole
in the wall I'm gone that guy's got
something going on no I don't want to
deal with how did it feel for you eh
oh I feel great yeah yeah I mean I
suppose actually in all honesty you know
you didn't have you know you could move
well in there prosthetics and stuff and
you know sometimes costumes if you have
a suit of armor or you know lots of
stuff weighing you down it can be
difficult sometimes the shoes then
especially like period pieces that is
difficult to walk and fight a bit
slippery so actually it's probably
better than a lot of yeah you know
secret fight outfit yeah and you don't
mind having what for swingin around
Arella
junk was it was a wonderful thing that
our generals bill corsets
it was just has such a great sense of
humor as well he made a fake willy and
he basically had this wonderful goes
working in the makeup department he had
her go around to find a condom that they
could stuff and she came back and she
said I've been to 12 sex shops today
looking for
non-lubricated condoms which is a
something I'd never heard of before went
to 12 SEC shops then her lawyers and she
was sitting there drawing veins on it it
was a and yeah we didn't use it in the
movie but it was I took home I can tell
all the ladies in the room you did you
do not want to see that penis because it
was testing it was a horrific I still
I'm still scarred Oh Carol it's gonna be
taking it a try
talk about sex oh it's okay it's okay
okay can I also just say about that
spicy because that thing with Edie with
the sticks that was the first thing they
sent me from London where ed was
training and and they're like look how
hard he's training and it's him going
gotta be [ __ ] [ __ ] in trouble
yeah worried oh yeah
this question is a Ryan Tim and and red
so you consider included any other x-men
in the film included like we wanted all
of them but yeah I mean in second it's
the skittles in the $47 right back to
that but yeah we we settled on Colossus
very quickly because we thought he
hadn't badly been treated as well as
maybe he could have been in in some of
the earlier films and negasonic teenage
warhead came off a list that Tim gave us
of potential names that we had and we
didn't know her powers but just that
name lit up and we just like oh my god I
have to use her so there were three
choices
Harry Ocelot yeah I saw a teenage
warhead and tar baby which is the worst
[ __ ] superhero
they like I couldn't believe it we're
just actually on us so yeah but but we
also had some other villains that were
in the original draft garrison cane and
wire and Sluggo they all ended up coming
to get Buster he's one of my favorites
no no not TAS me wasn't he unknown sir
was talked about right that guy's never
got a motive
yeah human being we had some other
villains and then we considered who
would cannonball we considered yeah you
know you you go through this process and
ultimately I think the cream rises and
that's what we got oh they realized they
had no money and they're so desperate
they're just that right would let's get
that cheap guy from London who's gonna
do the question is so amazing cuz I'm
Ryan said that like you know this such a
big house and I just
to keep it and only one of the things I
think you guys are all discovering today
you've never been in a room with Ryan
Reynolds is he's always the funniest guy
in the room and and I think we as
writers get a lot of credit for a lot of
the jokes that came from him just on the
day or you know he he doesn't at night
you'll be in the hotel anxious sleep
thinking about the next day and
returning and he comes in in the
mornings is who I've got something you
know and and that was the kind of thing
and then of course everybody everybody
says oh the screenwriters what a great
job they did on that joke and we have to
give credit for the great job come on it
was a collaborative effort you guys were
yeah the three of you I'm you know but I
mean again Laura may see you today
he's the quickest dude on the planet and
and we all benefit our original
screenplay was one page and it just says
Ryan ad-lib between him and I'm Jay
Miller that was just bad meets evil God
you know EJ Gina Carano is just there
like I don't think we're gonna say
anything
take care wake up you're gonna say
congratulations to you guys cuz this is
definitely the blockbuster and everyone
is talking about it and I want to get um
you guys I hate everyone give them a
round of applause
and blu-ray and any words last words I
just want to thank you guys because I
have a 16 year old son who I met at him
the only time he talks to me is when he
wants food or money and he came with me
to the premiere he hung out with me so
thank you I just want to say my son is
25 years old and he said please mom
so my just like this he's the [ __ ] I had
to say that
just like that don't think you have to
say you got it I want to thank you guys
for the person who probably had to watch
the movie the most I still was into that
song by the time we wrapped production
they would go okay it's a credit rolls
let's just move on out of it now yeah I
just let it roll shoot hits you see
every head in comic-con yeah we might
have something we have film of like when
we're doing test we'd film the audience
right and you do it
and you can see Rhett in the back of it
in the back of the audience every
testing I mean when it just jumped in
there when you were on the bridge and
you're the oven that was amazing the way
it just popped it was great so thank you
for your song thank you and I know this
is you know you are you still doing
music cuz I know they know around you
rap as well I only on Saturday night
very drunk are you gonna get it now
they're gonna be right they're gonna be
right
not mine you guys are you know we grew
up with salt pepper and when I when I
got into the theater my agent salt and
pepper down now I sent it to meet you
guys I was like mop let's get a team up
yes yeah it's like wow you guys do this
so well you know you guys you guys
didn't seem bow girls guys they were
coming out
you